サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダパナン エータンブッダナサーサナン
はい それでは 今日の説法になります
あの皆様も暗記していらっしゃるこのスワカートゥバウォターダンムというフレーズの意味は何なのかというね
で まあ仏教の場合は このまあ我々仏教徒はお釈迦様のことをもう何よりもすごい大事に尊敬するし
まあそれってある個人崇拝というよりも
ブッダを尊敬するということでね
それからダンマとサンガですね
ダンマは教え サンガはお釈迦様の弟子たちで
他の聖者になった人が方々なんですね
それでも誰でもこのブッダの教えがすごくすごいとは思ってはいるんです
まあダンマはね お釈迦様に説かれたダンマは
まあ信仰で言えば 過去のブッダたちもだいたい真理は同じですから
同じ真理を語られているということで
まあそれはほとんど絶対的な真理なんですね
そこでこういう風な文章がありまして
シアコーパナアナンデ トンマハン エオマス アティートサットカンパーバチャナン ナッティサッターティ ナコーパネータ
マアナンデ エヴァンヴェリ ガッタン バン ヨーワナンデ マヤ ダンモーチャ リメヨーチャ デシト パンニャット ソーウォーママ チェーナ サッタン
はい そういう言葉がお釈迦様がこのまあ涅槃に入られる前にいろいろ準備している間で
お釈迦様がおっしゃった言葉なんですね
いわゆるほとんど最後
それ意味は一応書いてあります
アーナンダよ あなたはこのように考えるかもしれません
死の言葉は過ぎ去った
死は存在しないと で もしかすると次の日か
あるいは次の日か はっきりわかりませんだけど
お釈迦様が亡くなったんで涅槃に入られたんですね
だからこれ世界で人間の初めて自分が亡くなる日を前もって設定するということは
これはブッダにしかありえないことで
だからブッダがだいたい半年
3ヶ月間前 私は涅槃に入りますよと発表してあったんですね
これから 3ヶ月間経ったところで涅槃に入ります
ですから この 3ヶ月の間でいろいろ後片付けをね
弟子たちのね 教えのいろんなことをなさっていたんですね
そのついでに あのアーナンダ尊者は大変ショックでいて
それでアーナンダ尊者にもいろいろ案内して
これからこうしなさい
ああしなさいとかね そこでお釈迦様が亡くなったら
このどうせ比丘たちはもうお釈迦様っていうのは自分の父親の感じで思っているし
みんななんかがっかりするだろうと思って教えたことなんですね
あなた方は私が亡くなったら
教えもないでしょう それからすべて我々は聖典パーリ経典と言っているところは
まあすべてと言っても
アビダーマのテキストはどうかなと学者が言ってますけど
で それは学者ではなくて
昔もアビダーマの 7つの本は
これはお釈迦様が直々教えた
教えられたものにはなりにくいということはあったんですけどね
ですから 我々は仏教 仏教とね
私たちはね 大乗仏教ではなくて
学んでいるのはお釈迦様に直々説かれたものなんですね
で お釈迦様ではなくて
誰かさんがどこかのおじいさんが教えたものが大乗仏教の教えになっているんですね
教えたものが書いたものとかね
例えば華厳経やら法華経というのはね
大して知らない誰かが書いたもんなんですね
仏説とは何の縁もないんですね
まあまあ それはそれでブッダの教えをパクって書いてるんだから
微妙になんとかかっこよく感じるんだけど
私も読んでみたんだけど
中身は何もないんですね
ただ信仰させようとするだけで
お釈迦様の教えでは 信仰はもうあまり当てにならない弱い者の性格で
理性のある人はそんな信仰に走らないという立場でしたからね
そういうことで こちらは人たちが 500人ぐらいいたんだけど
その時ほとんどみんな阿羅漢で
アーナンダ尊者すら預流果に達していたし
だから私が亡くなったら
教えも全部それで終わっちゃ消えたっていう風にね
思うでしょうと 当然 お釈迦様涅槃に至った時点で
新たに教教というのは加えていないんです
特に上座仏教 テーラワーダ仏教は
それはものすごい気をつけるんです
他のテキストはあるんだけど
それははっきりと何かバレるようにしてあるんですね
これはブッダに直々説かれたものではないっていうことをね
そういうバレるようにしなくちゃいけなくなったのは
字が出せない世界だから
何々さんが書いたっていうことをあまり書かないんですね
だから 身を自分の身を引いて引いて
テキストいくつかあるんだけど
書くんだけど まあ読んでもみると
まあこれはお釈迦様ではなくて
後の話ではないかとわかるようになっているんです
そういうことで ブッダの教えはね
すごい究極の宝物として
この上のない宝物として
人類に幸福を与える唯一の財産として
ずっと大事に守るということもやってきたんです
ずっといろいろトラブルがあったり
攻撃があったり 大変な歴史でしたけど
何があってもこのテーラワーダ仏教の世界は
ブッダの教えだけは絶対になくすようにはしませんということで頑張ってきたんですね
それから文明が発達してね
いろいろ機械が出来上がったところで
テキストにすることはできまして
それからはほんのちょっと一安心というところになっているんですね
で しかし ああなんだよ
このことはそのように見られるべきではありません
ああなんだよ およそあなた方のために
私によって示され 制定されてきた法と律
それが私の死後 あなた方の師となるのですと
ですから これパーリ仏教ではダンマとヴィネーなんですね
ヴィネーっていうのは生き方
いわゆる道徳的な教え
こちら律と書いてますけど
あれは決まってる単語で漢文でね
ヴィネアに律律戒律という風に書くんですね
ヴィネアの中で戒律もあります
戒律というのは形式的な項目
今皆様を受けた五戒と同じく
正式的な項目で でも人間の人生っていうのは
ある決まったある項目を守っただけで立派とは言えません
硬くなっちゃうんですね
何か項目があって 何かそういう条件があって
条件しっかり守るということ
それでそういう硬い人間になるんですよ
それではなくて ヴィパッサナーっていうのはディシプリン
英語で言えばね このディシプリンという言葉には
なかなかぴったしはめる日本語の単語がないんですね
まあ近いのはしつけなんですね
でも日本でしつけという言葉は子供に対して使うことなんですね
でもしつけなんで しつけっていうのはもういくら大人になっても
もう死ぬまで必要なものなんですね
しつけの中でこれこれやるなかれという風に項目も立てることはできます
でも項目だけしつけじゃないんです
もっと理解するものはいっぱいありますよ
例えば子供にちゃんと 6時半に起きなさいと項目を決めておくのは簡単だけど
それやったからといっていい子になるかというと保証はないんですよ
もしかするとしっかりそれを守るかも
しかし その規則がたまたま破ったからといって悪い子になったわけでもないんです
ちゃんと 6時半に起こることができなかった場合もある
その今日はしょうがないというふうにしてあげなくちゃいけない
この戒律のやり方はそんな程度なんですね
だから戒律っていうのは真剣に守るんだけど
破れる時もあります しかし
ディシプリンというのはそうじゃなくて
ずっと立派な人間として生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
たまたまいい 破っていいということじゃないんですね
たまたまふざけてもいいというようなことはないんです
まぁ 規則の場合はまぁ
守られない時も時々あります
はい そういうことで このダンマ教えとディシプリン
しつけをお釈迦様がちゃんと教えてあげたんですね
それがこれからブッダだよと
だから 仏教の人々 仏教徒の人々はお釈迦様は涅槃に入られたことは残念に思わないんですね
いつでも堂々と生きているんです
堂々と私たちを導いているんです
堂々と私たちを育てているんです
だから今ここにいる私も
ブッダに育てられたブッダのしつけを受けた人間の一人なんです
だから今 私の知識であろうか
いろいろ全てお釈迦様のものなんですね
だからそこは不思議なんですね
だから私はお経を勉強したり
経典パーリ聖典を勉強したりすると
やっぱり直々お釈迦様が厳しく言っているような
もう気持ちが現れるね
心の中で やばいとか怖いという気持ちもそっち
でも別にお釈迦様がいるわけではないんだ
涅槃に入ってるんで ただのテキストを開いて開けて読んでいるだけなんですね
それでも自分の情けないところに関係あるところが戒めが来ると
やばいことやったかということになる
だからこの誰だってブッダがずっと生きているんだと思わなくちゃ
そうするとちょっと神秘的になるんだけど
教えがあるんだから 例えば皆様方
ほとんど暗記してますね
慈悲とかね あれ ブッダの直々の言葉なんです
それを読む時でも ブッダが我々を戒めていると
我々にしつけしているんだという気持ちになると
すぐ心が変わるんですよ
本当に慈悲が入ってくるんです
心に それと なんとなく自分の生き方が変わってるはずなんです
だからそれを覚えてください
この苦労して苦労して
ブッダに言われたように生活しようしようがないちゃうと
そこでストレスかかっちゃうんです
だからストレスなく 気持ちよく
なんとなく心が変わって
性格が変わっていくんですね
その場合はこの自教ではなくて
それがお釈迦様がもう私に授業をやってるんだと
いう気持ちで読むと あ
これやらなくちゃ 守らなくちゃあかんということよりも
自分の心が変わっているんですね
そういう法の力っていうのはあります
それは偉大なる力なんですよ
法華経に書いてるバカで力ではないんです
これで人は変わるんだからね
人の性格変わるんだからね
人が良い人間になるんだからね
法の力っていうのはものすごい
ものすごいのです はい
それからそういうことで
ブッダの教えの特色は ６つありますね
で 今日のタイトルにはちょっと合わせませんだけど
ブッダの教えはなんですごいのかといったら
私はこれではなくて別な経典ににして喋りますけどね
ブッダはいかにすごいかっていう
私なりに発見しているものは結構あります
で 誰にもかなわないブッダの智慧の
計り知れないあの力 あるいはね
そういうのはこのフレーズには入ってないんです
教えはものすごいすごいということはね
他の経典たくさんあります
で 最近私はよく疲れていて
体力もなくてね だからこのみんな期待しているフレーズの説明でごまかそうということにしたんです
で このフレーズは この我々に
この法に対して信頼 信仰ではなくてね
信頼できるんだよと だから何の躊躇もなくこれやった
学んだ方がいいんだよという
この信頼感を作るために暗記させている
みんな仏教徒は暗記しているんです
それを暗記していない仏教徒はいません
大体小さい頃言葉を喋れるようになってくると
もうエピソードから終わり終わるまではもう覚えているんですね
１番目ソワカート ソワカートの意味は
この正しく説かれているっていう意味なんですね
で これでたまたま教会のテキストありますね
お経のね その訳は使いましたけど
よく正しく今日説き示されたということで
教義 実践方法と論理言語の上だけではなく
修行の結果においても完全な教えである
だからソワカートというよく説かれているという一言葉にものすごい深い意味があるんですね
これは完全に説かれているという意味もあります
意味が意味ですよ いわゆる何も欠陥何もない
そこでこの他の経典 ちらちらと言うんだけど
このこの完全に喋るっていう
ありえないんです なぜならば
完璧な言語っていうのは存在しないんです
言語とは文化なんです
文化とは 一部の人々が生きてる環境から出てくる経験に言葉
概念使っていることです
文化変わると言葉がなくなるんです
一番わかりやすいのは
ごちそうさまというのは英語では言えないんです
直訳しちゃうと超気持ち悪い言葉になるんです
例えば皆様方は英語のグッドモーニングということは日本語訳できると思っている？できません
おはようございますというのはグッドモーニングじゃないんです
全く違う意味なんです
そういうわけで 言語っていうのは
その文化から別な民族の文化になってくると困るものなんですよ
そういうわけで 完全なる真理を語るために言語を使うということは
これはもう無理 不可能なことなんです
なぜならば どんな文化の人であっても真理を発見していないんです
いくら科学が進んだからといって真理は発見できない
物質の真理は発見するんだけど
それでももう心が感情の膜があるんだから
もうその中から人生論を語ることはできないんです
ですから どんな文化の人も真理を発見していないし
だから何かの文化をの言語を使って真理を語るということは
もうありえない話なんです
しかし お釈迦様がもう生命のお釈迦様ほど智慧が誰にもないんです
一切生命の梵天 神々 もうみんな含めて
で お釈迦様がそれは自分の能力で語ってみせたんです
それはすごい びっくりするしかないんです
誰にもその真似できません
言語で言葉で何か言っちゃうと
必ずアンチテーゼが現れるんです
反対に意見成り立つ だから
このギリシャ哲学はヨーロッパの哲学ではね
どんなものにも反対にあれあるんだぞとかね
言っているのはその程度なんですね
俗世間の知識程度なんです
ブッダの言葉にアンチテーゼ成り立たないんです
それは誰もすごいと思わないのは変です
人は気づかない これってすごいやと
この言葉は変だけじゃなくて
とても悲しいことなんです
ブッダは反論成り立たないように言葉でかかった語ったこと
どんな言葉にも反論成り立たない
だからこれはすごい教えだよと
その時点で理性のある人だったらすぐ勉強してみるんです
だからみんなブッダの教えはもう日本の社会ではもう立ち入り禁止
公の場所とかね  こういう方でもいろいろごまかして借りないと
あの仏教でしょ ダメダメとかね
へっちゃらで言うんだけど
この日本人っていうのはどんな文化持ってますかね
自分たちも仏教文化なのに
それすら忘れるぐらい頭いいんです
だからこのやっぱり理性のひとかけらもないということになるんです
理性があったら 仏教は宗教じゃないとわかるんですよ
これは宗教じゃないとじゃないとわかったら
国の憲法を作る時も ブッダの言葉に従って
その言葉で作りましょうということになるんです
そうすると 国連の言葉ではだけじゃなくて
世界中誰でもそういうふうに
その方が平和な国になるんだよと
人間豊かになるんだよと
ということになるんです
なぜならば ブッダの教えで
人間本来持っている弱みを知り尽くしているんです
だから何を言っても人間っていうのはすぐすぐもう堕落
堕落して もうもうどうしようもない状態になっちゃうんですよ
だからどんな風に社会を作っても間もないうちに消えちゃう
だから歴史を学ぶときは
このゴールデンイーラ
ゴールデンイーラという黄金の時代
黄金であるで消えちゃったんですね
結局は だからそれは人間の平和にしても
なんだらかんだら国がね
20年も平和であったって
突然消えちゃうんですね
自分の国もね もう戦争終わってから
ものすごく平和で仲良くみんないたのに
頭イカれてる なんか何人かグループが出てきて
いきなりもうテロ事件を起こしちゃったんですね
だからそういう狙って国を破壊すると
それでイスラム教こそ世界一素晴らしい教えだとみんな信じてくれるぞとかね
で いかに頭イカれてるか
そんなことやると理性のある人ならイスラム教に行っただけで逃げるでしょうね
でも世界は逆で すごいイスラム教を保護している
日本の政府もね で イスラム教だったら大丈夫っていうことにしているんです
だからそういう理性っていうのは
世の中で人間にはないんですね
それで言葉完全に語れないっていうことに
今他宗教を引用したんだから
参考のために 例えばイスラム教
ユダヤ教 キリスト教 どちらでも
この私は唯一の神でありという言葉があるんですね
すぐ誰が言ったの？と反論なりたいでしょ
それで神が俺が言ってるんだよと
あんたが言ったら唯一の神になる
だったら同じ言葉自分に見えますから
というと 例えば私は唯一の神であると言ったら
あんた人間で何もできないくせにそんなこと言うなよと言えるでしょ
同じこと向こうに見える
あんたに何もできないんだよと
人間が頑張らなかったら何も成り立たないよと
だからこのそれでさらに頭が悪いことは
私以外の神を信仰したら永遠の地獄に落としてやるぞと
あ なるほど あんた以外にも神がいるんだということでしょう
だからこういう人は嘘を言ってるんですね
それだったら他の神々間で宣教でもいいし
戦争でもいいし やって勝ち抜かなくちゃあかんでしょ
そういう証拠はないね
だからこういう 例えば新約聖書にある言葉はギリシャで書いたものだから
ギリシャに仏教が伝道してあったんだから
ものすごくブッダの 言葉が入り込んでるんですね
この誰だってすごい尊敬する
このセーマンオブザマウントというは
何かどこかの山の上で崖ですけど
上で喋った言葉とかは
そのままダマパダの偈はたくさん使っているんですね
そこでこの慈しみは仏教の言葉なんですね
しかし 多文化の人々にはそれはなかなか理解できない
慈しみということは だから言葉が変わっちゃうと意味も変わってしまうんですね
で 我々英語でしか読めないんだけどね
例えばキリスト教でラブという言葉になっているんですね
それは正しくはないんですね
愛するというね それじゃない
愛するって感情ですからね
感情が心を弱くするんだから
愛することですごい力が発揮するっていうことはありえないんです
そこまで知らないんです
西方の感情的な愛の経験がありますから
そこはちょっと拡大してみる
例えばあのほっぺたに殴られたら
次のほっぺたを出してくださいとイエス様は言ってるんですね
だから言いたがっているのは
恨みを持たないようにと
でも見てみたらバカなバカじゃない？ということにもなりますね
だって右に殴られたら左も出しちゃって
私は左も殴っちゃって
一回で済むはずでしたのに
二回も苦労する羽目になるんですね
でも言いたかったのはそれじゃないんです
言いたかったのは 悪い人に対しても
あなたに害を与える人に対しても
恨みを持たないよというブッダの教えなんです
それが文化変わっちゃうと
あの完全であることは消えちゃうんです
ブッダの言葉はもっと完璧ですけど
私の今ちょっと訳していますけどね
害を与えても恨みを持たないで
なんで？と言ったら 恨んだらあの人困る
あなたが困る 私が困る
じゃあ生まれ 恨みはあんた何年持つ？だからもう論理成り立ってるでしょ
殴った痛みは何年持ったんですかと
何時間ですかと すぐ痛みが消えたでしょうに
そこで恨み持っちゃうと
何年でも何十年でも自分が困る悩む羽目になるんだからバカだからやめなさいと
という意味になるんで
だからそちらで誰かに異論立てることできる？できない
じゃあ自分が恨み持たなきゃ
向こうは二度と攻撃するかもしれませんとかね
攻撃しません 二度とだけ殴ったりしません
で だからこれはちょっと言ったのは
このお釈迦様以外は完全に語るとはできない
他宗教が言うのは これ神の言葉だよ
だから異論作るなよと脅すんです
脅ったならば その教えは不完全であるとお釈迦様は言うのです
次々その言葉出てくると思いますけどね
そこで正しく説かれていることっていうのは
真理をもう誰にもわかりやすく説かれている
面白いことは このインド文化以外の人々も理解できる
もっと面白いことは インド文化の連中には理解できなかったんです
インドで仏教はひとかけらもないんです
考古学的に お釈迦様はインド人だということを示すことはほとんど無理なんです
いっぱいありますけど
場所とかはね 年代測定してみたら
もう起源線には入らないんですね
自分の国では起源線の証拠っていうのはいくらでもあるのに
ということは 私はもうインド人がもうもう初めからもう頭が悪いとと悪口を言うんです
しかし ブッダの教えっていうのは
もう世界中誰にでも 不完全な言語に翻訳しても理解できるような不思議なパワーがあるんです
それ不思議ではなくて
正しく説かれているということなんです
そちらの神秘がないんです
智慧の勝負なんです お釈迦様は私は智慧は第一
私によりすごい智慧は誰にもないんだ
私という言葉を使っていないんだけどね
でないとおっしゃっているんだから
証拠はあるんですね そういうわけで
仏説ならすべて完璧に書かれている
それで真理だけではなくて
実践方法 どうやって心を清らかにするのか
どうやって心の次元を破るのかと
どうやって完全たる自由になるのかというと
こういう風に こういう風に
こういう風にやってみてくださいと
そういうのは一つも間違いなくすべて解き明かしているんです
お釈迦様 私はブッダになって悟ってみんな悟っちゃうと
私の立場が悪くなるっていうこと全くないんです
みんな悟れと みんな仲間になれと
だから最初は 60人の方々が悟ったところで
我々はもう 61人いるんだよと
同じ仲間がお釈迦様は平等に見ているんです
阿羅漢 阿羅漢は今 61人いますよと
ブッダも自分を阿羅漢として見て仲間同じ平等の
だからそんなことは他の宗教にはありえないんです
この本当に平等 だから俗世間の人々はもうボディーは still していない輪廻の生命だからね
でもみんなにどうぞこちらの世界に来てくださいと
悩み苦しみのない世界に来てくださいと言っているんです
はい それについていろいろさらに説明ありますので
それに行きます 注釈書では
これパリヤってダンマについて語っているんだと
パリヤってダンマっていうのは言葉の教え
いわゆる我々普通知っている経典ですね
経典は完璧に書かれているんだと
でも注釈書は扱っているべきところいっぱいあって全然扱っていないんですね
私はそれを調べて まあこの人々の理解は浅いなと思っちゃったんだけど
あれはちょっと自我が張り過ぎだからやめたんです
考えは で 注釈書ではよくあるフレーズ使ってますね
お釈迦様が自分の教えはアーディカルヤナマジェカルヤナパリウーサナカルヤナという言葉使ってますね
要するに喋ると喋りの最初のところ
みんなに話す かけて この話題を持ってくる
最初のそこは素晴らしく喋るんだよと
人間もいますね もう講演始めるとすごく面白くて
ああ すごいと興味抱くんだけど
まあ五分ぐらい経つとどんどんどんどん落ち込んでいくっていうか
面白くなくなるというね
ブッダは突然みんなびっくりしちゃって
話を聞きたくなるような
素晴らしく始めるんですね
それからマッジーカルヤーナ
話の真ん中にあるボディですね
本当の話になってくると
またびっくりからびっくりと理解から理解へと進んでいくんです
それから次にパリオーサーネカルヤーナ
結論のところ そちらになったらなおさら驚いて終わっちゃうんです
だからそうやってブッダの教えってよくケース書いてるんですね
お釈迦様が説法を比丘たちよと始めた時から終了するまで
みんなじーっと一貫して聞いているんだと
ずっと集中して 周り何が起こるのかと気がつかない
それぐらいこの言葉の使い方はものすごいんです
だって人間言葉で聞いてるんだから
だから今のある経典は
この喋ったものをそのままデジタルレコーディングして出しているものじゃないんだから
この省略してエッセンスだけ経典にしているんですよ
エッセンスだけでこんなもんだから
もし直々時間かけてお釈迦様が喋った時はいかなるものかと
だから聞いた 聞いた人がみんな悟りに達するんですね
だから心の雑念全部なくなっちゃって
そこで瞑想になるんです
話を聞くことだけで すごい簡単に集中力が生まれるんです
そういうわけで この初め
真ん中 終わりが素晴らしいというところで注釈書が説明してあるんですね
マッジーカルヤーナ教えの中は素晴らしい
パリオーサーネカルヤーナ結論のところは素晴らしい
アイデアの揺らぎ 脱線
曖昧がなく テーマに沿って涅槃という最終結論まで語られているんです
だから経典では頭があちらこちら行ったりしないんですよ
経典を読むと 一つのテーマにずっと行って
そこでちゃんと終わっているんです
大体お釈迦様がみんなに煩悩をなくして解脱に達しなさいということをずっと一貫して教えていたんだから
どんな経典でも結論部分では解脱に達しなさい
従って解脱を目指すべきですというところで終わるんです
言わなくても その結論は心に入っているんです
チュンダと大長老に喋ったところで
ずっと真理を喋って すごい感動的な説法なんですね
それで終わってから お釈迦様最後にエーターナチュンダアーラーマなんとかシュンヤーがある
なんとかなんとかあります
アーラムワルブクチティアニ
で終わって すぐそこら辺
いくらでも森がありますよと
空き家が空き地がありますよと
うん 頑張って 頑張ってって
だからそれはすごい感動的な終了なんですね
だから従って解脱に達するべきって言っちゃうと
ちょっとなんかオチがあまりないんですね
チュンダ長老のところでずっと解脱に達しなくちゃいけないところまで来て
話が変わる そこら辺 いくらでもいくらでも広々とした森があるんだからね
空き地がいくらでもあるんだから
うん 頑張ってと それからこのカルヤーナという素晴らしいということで
この人に自分の意見出して
異論出して アイデアをよぐすことはできないんです
で  4行の偈であっても
この特色はあります 偈で歌で歌っているお経もありますから
たった 4行の偈をとっても
全部揃ってます  因縁とテーマ
テーマですね まあ因縁って何で書いたか私も覚えてない
人々の間で話題になっている出来事をテーマにするので
興味深く聞くことができます
それははじめよろしい
所詮ですね お釈迦様は自分で勝手になんか変なテーマ考えてこないんです
みんななんか興味ある
現在みんなの間で話題になっているテーマから始まるんですよ
時々比丘たちの中に入る時でも
あんた方は今私が入る時
突然中断されたんですけど
何の話をしていたの？って聞くんです
何の話が私が入ると中断にする
中断することになったの？と
そうすると そのお坊さんたちの比丘たちは
お釈迦様が来る前に 我々はこういうことを喋ってましたよと
言ったら そこからお釈迦様は言うんです
だからみんなお互い話し合っていたテーマ
そのままずっといくんですよ
そんな話ではなく 私はこういう話をするために来たんだよということはないんです
だから私たちの場合は
それがすごいハンディになっちゃって
テーマを先に決めちゃうんですね
本当はその場で今流行っているアイデアで
今みんな話題にしていること
そういうところから始めた方が
聞く人々にとってはスムーズに聞くことができるんですね
それからたとえ話 エピソードなども使って分析して語る
それからそのテーマについて
あのところでこうなった
こういうところでこうなったとかね
あるいはわからないポイントだったら
たとえ話を出したりしてちゃんと分析するんですね
それは真ん中のところ
人が歩むべき道とゴールは涅槃ですね
を示して終了する それは終わり
よしということになるんです
これもブッダにしかできない仕業なんです
真理を語る 真理を語るって言って一方的に語ってないんですよ
面白いでしょ 一度たりとも一方的に語られてないのに
真理を語ったんです 人間に興味ある話題から
ですから 仏教の中でいろんなものが入ってますよ
政治論やらね 子育てのことやら
家族のことやら何でもあります
しかし それがメインテーマじゃなくて
それでアクセスするんですね
それから 完全な道 悪を起こさず善に達して生きる方法を最初におしゃる教える
これはシーラということなんですね
みんなに普通にこうしなさい
こうしなさいと 日常生活の中から日常生活を整理整頓する方法を教えてあげるんですね
それでみんなあ そうですね
そうですねとかね やっぱりそうした方が楽だとかわかるんですね
みんなの日常生活から話し始めるんです
それは仏教の戒律のシーラのところなんです
道徳のところなんです
ヴィパッサナーのところなんです
心が清らかにして成長させて統一する
サマーディを作る方法を語る
それから混乱して悩んだり苦しんだりしている
そのあなた方の心っていうのは
なんかもう戦争中みたいだからね
体が落ち着いたってもね
じゃあ次 心を落ち着くようにしましょうと
まず生き方ね 喋るときはこうしなさい
他の周りの人々にね こういう風に対応しなさいとかね
商売をやっている場合は
こんな感じで こんな気持ちで商売しなさいとか言うと
みんなその通り その通りってもう納得しているんですね
次に はい まあそれはできたところで
それでもあなたの心の中はね
ごちゃごちゃでしょ？だから心の掃除もしましょうよと言って
サマーディ世界 ちょっと瞑想する方法とかね
呼吸 呼吸で心を落ち着いてもらうこととかね
教えるんです それは完璧に語る
もうすべて禅定に入れるところまで
それは中身が真ん中よしというところになるんです
だからシーラ サマーディ
パンニャー 三学ですね
最後にすべて無常だからね
いくら頑張っても あなた方はね
いくらサマーディがあってもね
無常だよ そんなのは消えますよと言って
どうにもならん精神を作っちゃって
解脱に導くんです ヴィパッサナー実践を教えて解脱に導く
それは終わりがよしということになるんです
それであの三学を参考しましたから
わざわざ三学を書きません
それは戒定慧と漢文でよく言っているところなんですね
一 シーラ 戒律 道徳を完全に語る
俗世間の知識から加えるべきものも
ブッダの教えから削除するべきものもありません
ブッダが説かれている道徳からね
何も削除することはできません
普遍的に道徳を語っているんです
俗世 紀元6世紀 紀元前6世紀の人間であろうと 21
世紀の人間であろうか
道徳はブッダが説かれた道徳を守るしかないんですよ
本当は守ってないんだけどね
なぜならば ものすごく客観的に科学的に道徳を語っているんです
で 世間の道徳はなんなのかと
信仰に汚染されているんです
あるいは命令しているんです
人の命令は その人いる時だけ守ればいいんです
俺が死んじゃっても こういう風にやりなさいと言ったとしても
死んでしまえば別に守る必要はないんです
我々生きてる間でこれこんなことやっちゃったら
ただですみませんと言ったら怖くて守る羽目になる
法律っていうのはそういうものだからね
脅しでしょ 法律は だからバレなきゃ誰でも破るんです
で そういう脅しも何もなく
客観的にこういう風に生きるべきであるとシーラを教えているんですね
それでお釈迦様は参考にするのは
生命とはどんな仕組みなのかと
生命はどんな目的で生きているのかと
生命っていうのは 誰だって幸福になりたいと思っているんです
誰かが教えたわけじゃないんです
誰だって幸福になりたい
で 見たら幸福にならない
すべての生命は過去 現在
それから未来の生命まで幸福になりたいと頑張っている
でもなれない だからこの方法に問題あるんですね
それを訂正してあげる
直してあげるんです それが道徳世界なんです
シーラの世界なんです
だからシーラを守ったら
その人はものすごい幸福なんです
期待した目的に達しているんです
2番目サマーディ 統一ですね
心を統一して五根の次元を超える教えです
それでもっとちょっと超したことを教えるんですね
で 我々はこの五根から入るデータで知識だと思って
私はすべて知っているんだと
えらい勘違い あなた知っているのは
あなたの五根に触れたデータだけなんです
五根に触れないデータはいくらでもあります
例えば アメリカに一度も行ったことない人
私はアメリカのことなら知ってますよと言ったっても
まあ本本から読むものかどうかね
テレビで見た程度になっちゃうでしょ
だから五根から入るデータしか知らないんですね
世界中回っても 五根から入るデータしか知らないんです
そういうことで お釈迦様がもっと知識次元を超えましょうと
知る範囲を拡大しましょうと
だから心のこの範囲をね
ちょっと放出しましょうと
これは仏教用語で五蓋と言うんですね
五つのあの手錠が入っているんです
身動きできない 両手と両足と首につけておけば
どうやって動くんですかね
だからこの手錠を外してみましょうと
そうすると自由自在 手錠五つで止めている人が身動きできなくて
これこそ世界だ これこそ世界だと希望も何もなく生きていると
外してあげたら その人は行きたいところに行ける
見たいものは見える 聞きたいものは聞こえるということになる
だからネクタイ持ったとは
どこかの小さな部屋で
五つの手錠で閉じ込められたことなんです
だからそこら辺のことしか知る由もないんです
部屋の外で何が起きてるかはわからない
だから この五蓋を破ることを二番目に教えるんですね
それはサマーディという三学の二番目
三番目 パンニャー智慧ですね
ブッダが悟った真理を語る
そこで次元を破っていろんなことを知るようになったっても
まだまだダメですよと
全体的に存在はなんなのかを知る必要があるんだよと
それを教えてあげるんです
四聖諦を教えてあげる
それはパンニャーということになるんです
そういうわけで ブッダの教えといえば戒定慧なんです
一つのダンマパダの偈一つ取ってみても入ってますよ
長い経典ならテーマに分け分けるが
短い経典では順番に示す
例えば長部経典みたいな長い経典だったら
戒律のセクションは結構長い
サマーディのセクションも結構長い
で 最後の智慧のパンニャーのセクションも結構長い
しかし 四行の偈もありますね
四行の偈 あるいはちっちゃな経典とかね
そちらにもちゃんと戒定慧の三段階はしっかりあるんです
一個一個完璧に語られているんです
ブッダの教えは戒で終わる
定で終わる 慧で 慧だけで終わるとはありません
いきなりみんな煩悩なくして解脱に達しなさいと言っちゃうと
え？なんだこりゃとなるんですよ
そうすると完璧じゃない教えはスワカータにならない
だからブッダの教えは戒から始めて
定に進んで慧で終わる
それはどこでもお釈迦様
その決まりは破りません
そういうわけで 誰もえ？なんだそれやっと思わない
誰でも自分一人で もう私たちの説法も聞かないで
説法を聞くとすごく理解しやすくなるんだけど
もう日本訳でもドイツ語訳でもいいんだけど
読んでみると 誰でもなんだこりゃとは思わなくなるんです
はい それはスワカータ
正しく説かれているということになるんです
まだいろいろあります
正しく説かれているところで
この論理性 異論立てないこと
アンチテーゼは出せないこととかね
もっとこのあるんだけど
ちょっと難しいんだから
そこら辺はやめます  2番目に行きます
サンディッティコ 実証できる
いつでも誰にでも実証できる教えである
で 語ったのは語ったんだけど
この漫才師も物の見事に語ってるでしょ
その人々の言葉は完璧です
特にプロの漫才師なんかは
喋る場合は初め 真ん中
終わりまでちゃんと訓練してしてして暗記して喋るんですよ
だからいろいろネタ話をいくつか持っていて
それを暗記して テキストをね
それから繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し言って
言って言って もう長い間練習してから
自分の師匠が来る前にちょこちょこっと話をしたり
そうやってどんどん一人前になるんですね
だからそういう人々も
漫才は初め 真ん中 終わり
全て笑える話はするんだけど
意味がない どれぐらい訓練したんですかね
それから一つも実践できるものは何もないでしょ
笑って終わった ある日
ある人がお釈迦様にこう聞くんですよ
もういきなりなんかいろんな質問を出しちゃった
出す出す質問にお釈迦様は物の見事に順番で答える
ただ この人は あのね お釈迦様
お釈迦様は一人でいると
こういう風に妄想しますかと
人が来てこのような質問をすると
このように答える このような質問をされたら
このように答える また
このように出てきたら
このように答えるという法務やってますかと
言ったら そんなことやりませんよ
そんなこと答えますと
お釈迦様は答えたんです
ブッダには智慧があるんだよと
ブッダは知らないものは何もないんだよと
だから宿題はないし 質問いきなりどんな質問を出しても
物の見事に 答えている
それは一人前やるんです
スワカータところに はい
俗世間でも漫才のエピソードだけでも完璧に喋る人々はいるんです
しかし それで終わり 何も人生の役に立っていない
お金も払ったのに 2番目はこのサンディッティカ
これは証明できるんです
いわゆるその通りであると人に確かめることはできるんです
その方法でいたって簡単
なんで誰にでも実証できるんですかね
だってすごい ものすごい
だってすごい研究所がなければとかね
あるでしょうに 素粒子の研究のためになんとかでなんかでっかいあれ
機械作ってるでしょ 国いくつかまたがって地下で
だからあれちょっと動かしちゃうともう大分お金かかっちゃうんですね
いわゆる太陽で受けてるような感じで
このなんていうか 核合成することできるのかと
核を破壊することは人間にできる
できてひどい目に遭う
合成しちゃうとすごいエネルギーは出ますけど
もうひどい目に遭うことはできないんだけど
そのエネルギーがない
もともと太陽には自分のエネルギーがありますからね
融合することはできます
核融合 そのために作った機械はもういろんな国から大金出して
もうヨーロッパでね  ３つの国
4つの国またがって 地下でそれぐらい長いトンネルが必要なんですね
そこで超一流な磁気の力でこの素粒子を回すんですね
あんまりにもミスになってぶつかったところで合成するということですけど
あんまりそっちを実験していないみたいですね
では ブッダの教えは誰にでも実証できるということはどんな話かと
それは自己の心を見るんです
だから実験室あるでしょう
核融合は生きてない 生きている人に興味あるだけ
一部の人々に あるいは核を破壊することは
もう一部の人間だけに興味があってね
だから生きることは一番大事な生きるということは
心を活動していることなの
別にあの あれじゃないんですね
生きるということは 自分の心活動している物質
物質あることでもないんです
はい それでお釈迦様がある人に説かれた経典の一部出してますよ
パーリ語で読んでみなさんパーリ語知らないんだからね
ラットコーブラームナラーゲーナビブートーパリヤディーナチットアッタバヤバーダエピチェテーティパラバヤバーダエピチェテーティウビャビャーバヤバーダエピチェテーティ
チェータシカン・ドゥッカンドーマナッサンパティサンウェデーティラーゲーパヒーネーナ
エヴァアタバヤバダチェーテーティナパラバヤバダチェーテーティナウビヤバダチェーテーティナチェテセカンドドッカンドーマナッサンパティサンヴェーデーティエワンピコブラフマナサンディッティコダンモホーティ
2番目はサンディッティか実証できる
こういうことだとお釈迦様は注釈しているんです
じゃあ日本訳見てみましょう
それはそれで格好いい訳で
私の訳ですから あまり格好いい日本語にはなってないんです
バラモンよ 欲がある人は欲に支配されて欲に悩ませ悩まされている時は
自分の破壊に陥る 他を破壊に陥る
両方両者です 両方を破壊に陥る思考をします
彼が心で悩み苦しむことになる
で 人の心に欲が入ってくると
欲に支配されちゃうと
もう理性がなくなる そうすると
いろんなくだらんことを妄想しますね
ああしたい こうしたい
それで自分が悩み苦しむんですよ
あるいは人のことを 妄想したりやったりすると
その人にも迷惑 あるいは両方にも迷惑になる
そういう思考によって
その人は激しく悩み苦しむことになるんだよと
欲がなくなったならば
自己破壊 他の破壊 両者の破壊に陥る思考はしない
心で悩み苦しむことはことにならない
簡単でしょう そうすると
その人は自己観察しているならば
自分が欲に抑えられている時は苦しんでいたんだと
欲がない時 自己観察すれば気楽でしたと
例えば異性と喋る場合でも
欲があって喋る場合はいろんなストレスがかかってくるんですね
もしかすると相手に迷惑をかける可能性もある
それで欲が全くない普通の心で異性と喋ったからといって
どちらにでも問題ないんです
すごくうまく平和で話は終わるんです
それがダンマがサンディッティクという意味であると
お釈迦様 それは訳していないんです
その言葉を忘れちゃった
えワンピダンモサンディッティコというのはそのようなものであると
それでお釈迦様 経典長いんだけどね
怒りに頭がやられた時は
自己破壊 他破壊 両者破壊の思考をして
それから精神的にはちゃめちゃ苦しみますよと
怒りがなくなった瞬間で楽しくない？安穏じゃないんですかと
それが私の教えがサンディッティがすぐ実証できますよと
言っていることは本当であると
あなたに実験することはできますよという話なんです
それで実証とは自己観察なんですね
自己観察 をすると 仏法は自ら実証できる教えだと
ちょっと間違いありますね
文章には実証できる教えだと発見できます
人は自分を観察するならば
どんな人間でも 信仰はどうでもいいんです
自分を調べるならば ブッダの教えは真理であるとわかるのです
ブッダは神秘 神の話 永遠の天国の話をしないんです
インドの宗教は人間が妄想した神話に基づいてできているんです
だからお釈迦様はインドで喋ったんだから
まるっきり違う話をしたんです
神話の話は全くない まあたまたまたとえ話に出しますけどね
それでも自己観察に値するって結論に終わっちゃうんです
なんでそういう文章を書いたのかというと
やっぱり他の宗教の教えっていうのはね
どうしても神秘神話から始まります
証明することは不可能なところから始まるんです
初めは私がいたんだ 私があれやこれやったとかね
言ったっても どうやってね
それ実証できるんですかね
実証絶対にできない自我エゴの話は仏教で普通の宗教では自我があるんだ
魂があるんだとかね でも魂あることは未だに発見していないんです
永遠の魂あるならば見つかるはずなんです
この体の中に これはないんだから見つからないんです
だから仏教では自我の話はないんです
人の悩み苦しみは心の汚れのせいであると説かれている
お釈迦様が言うのは あなた方には悩み苦しみありますよ
落ち込みとかね 希望通りにいかないわ
希望しなかったものは起きるわ
愛する人から別れなくちゃいけないわ
もう何といいますか 嫌いな人と付き合わなくちゃいけない
これって楽じゃないでしょうにと
それはそれぞれすぐわかるんですね
自己観察すると なるほど
あんた知っている それはあなたの心の問題だよと
気に入らない人と一緒に仕事をする羽目になりましたと
だからあの人悪いっていうのは一般人の考えなんですね
あなたの心に問題あるんだよと
人は気に入る 気に入らないと判断したところに問題あるんですね
そういう判断しないで
そのまま生きてみれば
何のこともないでしょ
だから自己観察すると
すぐブッダの教えは正しいとわかりますね
従って人は自己観察してみるんです
うん 今ここで体験できる
サンディッティカにはもう一つ意味があります
すぐ結果が出ますという
清らかな心を育てることが誰にでも体験できるのです
これには資格は必要じゃないんです
なぜならば 汚したのは自分だから
掃除すればいいでしょうに
掃除不可能 掃除不可能とか
俺にはそんな資格はないよ
何言ってるんだ 自分で汚しちゃって
だから汚したところは綺麗にしなさいと言っているだけだから
もうすぐできますよ もしも一切無常
苦 無我だと発見したならば
預流果などの悟りにも達するんです
だから自己観察すると
無常だ無常だ 全部変化するんだ
因縁によって成り立っているんだとかね
痛みがなったら なんで俺が痛いのか
なんで不幸なのかと思ったら
妄想だけで あ これがあって
これがぶつかって痛みがある
これは因果法則だとわかったら別に楽でしょう
その人々は 仏説は自分自身の経験として発見するので
得体を知らない何かを信仰する必要は消えます
例えば無常 苦 無我と分かったら
あ なるほどと心は清らかになるのです
それだけで自由になる
何か にも困らなくていいんで
なぜならば何でも無常だからね
困る必要ないでしょ？あれで困ってる
あれで困ってると言っちゃうと
そのあれはずっとあるんですね
よく言うでしょうね 私はこれこれこれで困ってるんだと
そのこれこれがずっと変化してないような態度でしょ
それは無常だから変化するんですよ
だからそんな気にしなくていいんです
そういうことで すべて無常だと分かった人にとっては
完全な解放 心の解放が生まれてくるんです
それでそれも自分で感じるものでしょ
他人に分からない ですから
自己観察ですぐ経験できる教えなんです
世間にすべての見解から
世間にあるすべての見解から解放されます
もう一つ 我々は見解でやられているんですね
あの人はこう言った この人はこう言った
ネットでこう書いている
フェイスブックでこう書いている
ツイッターでこう書いている
あれやこれやとか意見で悩んでるんだ
そんなのは生ゴミだからですよ
気にしなくてもいいということになるんです
それからサンディサンディッティコに別な意味もあります
これは注釈書の話なんですね
サンとは正しい 聖なるという意味です
ディッティとは見解ですね
すべての邪見を破って正見になるからサンディッティコですと
ブッダの教えを理解すると
心はすべての見解から綺麗になるんです
人の意見だからすごいなとなくなっちゃうんです
真理を知ってるんだから
人は真理知らないんだから
基本的にはすぐ結果が出る
誰にでも確かめることができるという意味になります
また サンディッティコの注釈です
修行の結果を出すために決して時間がかからないのですと
これ注釈書に書いているものなんです
修行したら 1 日後  1 年後
死後結果が出るなどはなどの教えではない
これ仏教だけなんです
宗教は死後の結果ですね
例えば真宗はまあ死後阿弥陀様のところに行くんですね
待たなくちゃいけないんです
だからそういう考えもすぐ変です
人には完璧に語れません
あんた死んじゃったら
すぐ阿弥陀様のところで永遠な幸せなの
だったら早く死ねでしょ
なんで 1 日もこの世にいるのかいと
だからいつでも人いうことに反論はなく
成り立つんです 反論成り立つならば
その人は悟ってない 智慧がない俗人なんです
仏教は特色はというのはすぐすぐ結果出る
皆様 私はまあまあ 今 3年も瞑想しているんだけど
まだ悟ってないんだぞとかね
それは皆様の妄想の結果であってね
30分瞑想したっても
それぐらいは心は変わっているはずなんです
何か学んでいるはずなんです
ものの見方が微妙にでも変わっているはずなんです
ただ 瞑想と言って妄想する場合は
まあわからないんだけどね
だから完璧に説かれているんだから
言ったことも完璧にやらなくちゃいけない
それだけは私の経験 誰もやってくれない
その場で修行に適した結果が得られるのです
この言葉は解脱に達する時の話です
マッカチット同心 次の瞬間にタダチット家心が現れるんだと
いわゆる瞑想していて
ヴィパッサナー瞑想ですよ
して マッガ道に帰ったら
次もう解脱の結果なんです
そこは間時間ないんです
すぐ次の瞬間で起こるのだと
はい 次の説明に行きましょう
アカーリコーという カーラっていうのは時間なんですね
時間と関係ないんだと
だから私はあえて変な言葉で真理は永遠と永遠という言葉は屁理屈で
それは初めから言っておきます
もう理屈で成り立たない
仏教では使わない単語なんですね
お釈迦様も でもあえて間違った単語を使ったんです
知識で発見する真理 事実はその通りにならないんです
知識っていうのは 皆様
歴史本を読んだり 発掘したり
あるいは研究したり 実験したり
いろんな真理を発見するでしょう
しかし その通りということはないんですね
新たなデータが現れたら
考えを変えなくてはならない
これは世の中の普通なこと
科学者は一人も私は最終的な真理を発見しましたと言わないんです
自分が取ったデータによってこういうストーリーを作れましょうというだけで
次の世代で別なデータが発見したら
考えは変わりますね 私たちが真理だとするすべては時間リミットがあります
薬飲んでるでしょ  20年前飲んだ薬は今は出さないね
作ってもない もう変わってるんです
実世界の世界でも 例えば手術世界ありますよね
かなり昔から人々は手術を受けたでしょうに
まあどんどんその技術変わって変わって変わって
今ものすごく楽になっているんですね
まあまあ 例えばほとんどレーザーで切ってレーザーで焼いて止めるとか
だからあれ スカルペルを持っている持つよりは精密にできる
かなり楽ちん そういうわけで
さらに進むと 精密なロボットが
100分の1ミリの 100分の1の精密さで手術してくれるかも
心臓の場合は胸開けなくちゃいけないんだけど
穴2つを開けてできますよと今言ってるんだからね
あなたからちょっと穴を開けて
そこロボットが修復してからあれを外して穴を塞ぐだけという
今まだやっているかどうか分かりませんだけど
そういうふうに読みました
仏法には普遍性があります
使用期限 賞味期限がないんです
ありのままの事実を発見して語っているので
新しい考えによって変える
訂正することはあり得ない
仏教は訂正できません
改変することは不可能です
改悪はできます 宗派仏教は改悪したんだけども
これからそれでもしかしくないと思います
ダンマの 4番目の特色
教えのね エイヒパッシコって教会のテキストでは来たれ見よということがありますね
というのは 完全に開放された教えです
完全に開放しているんです
ということは 滅教ではないのです
一般人に 言ってはいけない教えではない
特定の人 イニシエーションを受けた人のみに明かすべき教えではないと
ちょっと文章おかしいんですけどね
誰でも来て調べてみなさいとオープンにしているのです
神々含むいかなる生命にも
教えを調べたり 真偽を確かめたりする自由があります
仏教っていうのは 特定の人に教える教えじゃないんです
イニシエーション受けないと教えませんということでもないんです
神々 人間 誰でも聞いてください
調べてください 真偽を議論してみてくださいとかね
すべて開放してオープンなんです
うん 学ぶ人に条件をつける
教えなどは真理を知らないからと完全に語れないからだとお釈迦様は説かれているんです
この言葉をあまり議論しないという場合は
何か自分に自信がないんですね
議論しろよと仏様が言うんです
だから人々はいい加減に何か妄想でね
宗教を作ってるでしょ
で 日本のいろいろ新興宗教のもっとちょっと調べたら
ちょっとした幻覚が落ちただけで怒っただけで
起きただけで えらい宗教作っちゃってみんな黙ってるんです
そんなだから言ってることはあちゃめちゃになるんです
まあ世の中いつでもそういうこと
だからブッダは完璧に語って真理を語っているんだから
別に隠すものは何もないんですね
お釈迦様が言うのは 自分の教えに条件をつけたら入信しなかったら教えたけど
私は昔 真如苑のね 聖典くださいと言ったら
あなたにはあげるわけに
上の人から聞いてみますと
言ったら ある女性が案内したんだけどね
言ったらもうすごい時間かけちゃって
30分ぐらい 上の人も態度でかくてなかなか会ってくれないんですね
上ってそんなに上の人でもないんですね
そこらの事務所の誰かでしょうね
言ったら私にずっと責めたんですね
名前書いて登録して信仰しなさいと
向こうは名前書いた途端データバンクに入れちゃって宣伝に使う
私が言ったらすぐスリランカ人が行ったことのリスト持ってて
この人も来た この人も来てすごい感銘を受けて帰りましたとかね
私はああそう よかったねと
私はそういう人がいるところ来るならば
その場所にも一緒に行かないぐらいの信頼できない人々だと言ったんです
あまりも狂暴だからもう
それで 信仰していないから聖典をあげるわけにいきませんというのはね
教えがあちゃめちゃからでしょう
だから その 30分の間で私にも力がありますからね
売っているところを見て
何のことなく まあこの本とこの本とこの本ちょうだいと言ったら
何のことなく売ってくれたんですよ
それでその人はもうものすごい焦って
あの すみませんだけど
これはもうできないみたいですね
持ってはいけないみたいですよ
あなたは信仰していないんだから
真如苑をとかね ああ そうですか
じゃあ帰りましょう しょうがないねとか
私は嘘じゃないでしょ
しょうがないね それだと言って
駅であのね 実は持ってますけどと
その女性がびっくりしちゃって
あ これ大変 私はお金払いますから
どうぞ これは持ってはいけません
私は持ったらどうなるんですかね
そこで本を開けて読んでみたら
なんか頭イカれてる女の子とかね
ゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャ喋らせて
それ書いてるだけで文章一つ二つも繋がってないんですね
だからもう誰にでも読めない盲信がなければ
あれを拝むだけで そのまま私はゴミ箱に捨てたんです
それからもなんかスリランカ人の祭りがあった時も来て
ガチャガチャ言うわ言うわ言うわ
そしたら私はもうあれはこれはと言ってね
別の宗教をすすめるかな
こいつらなぜスリランカ人狙うんですかね
スリランカ人も二種類いますよ
相手に親切で あ そうですか
ありがとうございますっていう人もいるし
すぐ攻撃する人もいます
スリランカ人はそんな新興宗教にいることはもう無理です
いくらだらしない人であっても
とにかく来たら私はどうぞどうぞ読んでみまって言ったら
これは読んだことあるよね
読んだことある その人見ている間で捨てたんですけども
狙ってやるんで すごい態度悪いことをね
別に本来性格にはそういう問題ないんです
その場で実践的に捨てちゃうんです
そうすると その人はびっくりしちゃって
すごく気持ちがなくして欲しかったんですね
宣伝しよう 宣伝しようという宣伝というか
布教しよう 布教しようと
こちらでは無理だと この場所で理解して欲しかった
みんなに迷惑だから  はい
網目に邪魔をされると
太陽に自分の力を示すことはできません
夏 晴れ晴れた空であるならば
太陽が自らの力を見せます
輝きます 不完全な教えを隠した方が良いのですが
完全な仏説は晴れた空に輝く太陽のごとくオープンにするべきだと説かれています
ヴィワトウィローチダンモ
ダンモヴィワトはウィローチ
ダンマはオープンにした方が輝きますよ
だから いろんな宗教の人々やら
いろんな学問の人々やらね
心理学であろうか 医学であろうか
工学であろうか 誰でもいいんです
みんなオープンに勉強して議論するならば
教えが輝くんです 先天的に神を信じる
魂の存在を信じるなどの条件がないので
来たれみよの教えなんです
私はキリスト教を勉強していた時は
もうあんたいろんな議論するのはね
ここを間違っていることを間違っていると言っているのは
あなたは神を信じていないからよ
まず神を信じなさいと
そうすると全部そのまま当たり前でしょうに
神を信じる それで神が汝スマナサーラにはその 3本付いているんだよと言ったら
はい わかりましたというしかないでしょうに
神を信じているんだから
信じてない野郎はえ？そんなのないんだけどと
それでいえ あなたに見えないんだけど
ありますよ 見えないものをどうしたことないやと反論できるんですね
だから まあそうやって条件つけるんですよ
条件をつけたら その教えが間違いなんです
問題なんです  注釈書に別な意味があります
一 ブッダの教えはリアリティ
現実的です 手に取った宝石が
これ注釈のアイデアです
手に取った宝石がない場合は
手に宝石取ってない場合は
この宝石見よと手を開けて見せることはできません
だから手の中で宝石がないんです
こちらすごい宝石がありますよと
40カラットだよと ルビーだよと
あるいはなんとかだよとかね
いくらでも見えますよ
見せなきゃ なんで見せないの？ないからなんです
宝石を握っているならば
ほら見よと言います 例えば本当に 40カラットの宝石を手で握っているんです
ほら これ 40カラットの 2,000万円の価値あるものだよと見せることできるでしょう
だから仏教は真理だから
来たれ見よなんです 怖くないんです
心の成長と解脱を現実的なので来たれみよと言うんです
だから必ず心は成長する
必ず心は清らかになる
必ず解脱に達する ですから
やってみなさい 学んでみなさいと無条件で言うんです
お釈迦様なら注釈書と違って
じゃあ議論してみなさい
異論立ててみなさい 私は言っていることは間違っているのだとわかっているならば言ってみなさい
これは梵天 神々 人間 誰にもできませんよと言うんです
それぐらい来たれみよなんです
2番目の特色ってピュアリティ
それは注釈書のアイデア省略したんです
汚物などは来て見てとは言えないね
来て来て 見て見て見て
私は漏らしましたよと
赤ちゃんさえ嫌がるんです
それを他人に見えないように隠す必要がありますね
仏法は完全清らかな教えなので
来たれ見よになるんです
皆様の家でもぴったしピカピカの掃除していると
お客さん来るのは全然大丈夫なんですね
だからはちゃめちゃ汚れていると
もうちょっと玄関で喋って帰そうとしているんです
これ言ってるのは本当は他宗教のため
他宗教ってのはすごい汚れた教えだから
隠すこといっぱいやと
はい 時間ないんだからさっさといきます
あと二つですね 五番目は大きな一考
実践さを涅槃に導き 涅槃へ導く
仏法を学ぶは学ぶ時は何のことなく
自分が成長や進化へ進んでいるんですよ
成長と進化 仏法を聞くだけでも心が清らかになるんです
聞くだけでもなんとなく心変わるんです
良い方に変わるんです
テロリストになりません
理性が現れる 成長する
実践してみると 一時的な清らかさ
成長 一時的な成長は現実的な本物になる
だから話を聞いたら 心はなんとなく清らかになった気分になるでしょう
でもすぐ忘れちゃいますね
忘れるとまた汚れちゃいます
ですから 実践してみると
二度と汚れない その通りになるんです
仏法を聞いて理解する人は
感情の奴隷で生きる惨めな人でなくなります
すべての生命は感情で生きているんです
判断は感情がするんです
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみなどなどの感情で
いつでも感情が優先です
感情が出来上がったら
やるべきことすらやらないで
感情が言うことをするんです
だから人間というのは惨めな奴隷な生き方やってますよ
感情の 仏道を学んでみたら
もし理解したらあれがなくなるんです
怒りがこみ上げてきても
すぐそれを抑えて消して理性で対応する
欲がこみ上げてきても
まだまだ悟ってない人はね
それは実行はしません
欲 これはやばい お仏出たから
その場でそこは処分して普通に対応する
そうやってすごい立派な人間になるんです
理性のある独立精神の人に成長します
仏法は実践する人を解脱涅槃へ導くのです
そういう特色があります
エーヒパッシコ 来たら見よ
それから来たら見よと言ったら考察するに考察に値する
オープンアイ オープン
あ オープンエコで間違った
人は何かの課題を心で考えたり考察したりしますね
普通は 課題を心にインプットします
無駄な課題を捨てるが
大事な課題なら真面目になる
我々はいつでも頭の中で考えています
いろいろな課題を入れちゃって
ウパナイティとは課題を心に入れることなインプットすることなんですね
オープンアイっていうのは
ウパナイティという動詞から出ているんです
オープンナイコーはウパナイティという場合はインプットするという意味なんですね
ブッダの教えは 心の中に入れて考察する価値があるのです
1 日中考えるなら ブッダの教えを考えてみなさいなんです
すべての課題よりも最高の価値があるんです
ですから オープンアイです
何よりもこちらに価値があるとわかるんですよ
実践する場合でも 瞑想課題を心で受けて受け取って観察するんです
瞑想する皆さんはあまりわからないんだけど
我々はこのカンマターナあげるという仕事をするんですね
一人一人に何か宿題をあげるんです
あげた宿題は その人を頭に入れて観察しなくちゃいけないんです
皆さんに言っているのは
この初期段階のカンマターナで膨らみ
縮み 感覚を観察しなさいと
そこから次々と真理を発見していきます
それで智慧が現れます
人は解脱に達します だから導くことは導きますよ
これはもう完璧にもう確かなんです
はい 最後に行きましょう
法の特色 ロコパッチャッタングエリタボウィンヨヒ
賢者たちによって各自で悟られるべきというのは教会のテキストなんですけどね
私はちょっと賢者という言葉にちょっと異論を作ってます
賢者というのは 賢者といったら私たちには関係ない
仏教は我々に関係ないという
賢者というのは大した意味じゃなくて
理性があるという意味なんですね
理性とは 感情 主観 先入観
好み 信仰 伝統 文化 価値などで心を汚すことなく
データに基づいて客観的に観察して知ることです
それでちょっと訓練すればできるでしょう
そのまま客観的なデータを観察するだけです
それができれば理性なんです
やっぱり日本文化ではテーラワーダ仏教はもう合わない
やらないとかね 何でしたっけ？あの聖徳太子はテーラワーダ仏教知らなかったんだから
日本人には合わない 馬鹿げた話でしょ？だからそういう馬鹿げた話と言ったっても
これ文化に価値を入れてるんですね
歴史に価値を入れてるんですね
聖徳太子という日本歴史のすごい偉い人に価値を入れて
そこでもう色眼鏡が落ちてくるんですね
はい そういう風にいろんなこの
そこをちょっと外すことはそんなに難しくないと思いますけどね
仏教を理解するためには理性かどうしても理性が必要です
目の前のことを言ってるんだからね
今体験することについて語っているんだからね
他人に理性を開発する方法を教えられますが
理性を与えることはできませんね
これは問題なんです はい
理性あげますと  1,520万20円ですよと
これはできませんね こうすれば理性が現れると方法は教えられますよ
理性が各自で知ることなんですね
理性が各自で知る それでまずいろんな先入観を置いておいて
信仰も置いておいて 純粋科学者の精神で
話を理解して聞いて それから実践してみると
自分自身で実証するんです
自分の理性で現象を観察します
お釈迦様はあの世の話しないんだから
現象について語っています
真理を発見して解脱に達します
私は勉強しているから
あなたは勉強しなくても結構ですとは成り立ちませんね
他人が食事したから私の空腹感が消えませんね
仏道は苦しみをなくす教えなので
各自で発見するべき真理なんです
苦しんでいるのは私ですから
悩んでいるのは私ですから
私の心が汚れているんだからね
だから各自で発見するべきということはあります
仏教で なんかそれはみんなこの
ちょっとネガティブに聞くかもしれませんだけど
あの 例えば弁当を配ると
弁当配ります みんな並んでくださいと
みんなの分なかったら
やっぱり弁当券を渡さなくちゃいけないね
はい 弁当券持ってきてください
券持ってないとダメですよ
で  100枚ありますよと
しかし こちらにいる人数分 10
もまた倍に増えても大丈夫
お弁当いっぱいあるならば
何のことはないね 大丈夫ですよ
焦らなくても結構です
みんなの分がありますよと
十分 そういうふうな話なんです
この各自で発見するべきというところは
私も人間だから悟れます
あなたも人間だから悟れます
それですごいことを言ってますけど
なんとなくネガティブっぽく聞こえちゃうんですね
やっぱり神様を信じた方がいい
神様 イエス様は受難したんだからね
そのパーツで私も天国に行きますよとかね
そんなの嘘でありえないんですけどね
阿弥陀様がなんとか勢至菩薩の時修行したんだだから俺は修行しなくても
ああいうのは邪教でね
これは大丈夫で 誰だって人間だったら悟れますよね
みんなの分がありますよと
究極の幸福はみんなの分がありますよと
仏教では それはいつだって教えがある限りあります
知識は世界で知識 世界では縦の関係があります
仏教では俗世間と出世間という
仏教も区別しています
俗世間と出世間 皆各自で真理を発見して解脱に達するので
各者の間では縦の関係はありません
だから縦の関係なくなるんだっていう意味も入っているんです
水に水を入れて区別入れても区別ができないようにです
水にもうちょい水を入れたら
後から入れた水 前からというのはできませんね
そのように仏道に入ったら
各自で自分で聖者の世界に行くことになります
はい それで終わりです
どうもありがとうございます
法話をありがとうございました
中で心の汚れについてちょっとあったので
それに関連してアドバイスをいただきたいと思うんですけれども
ゴキブリとの付き合い方なんですけれども
1年半ぐらい前に お隣のおうちがリフォームをした時に
一斉に私の部屋にゴキブリが来るようになりまして
で 私は教えを教えていただいてから生命を殺すのはしていないので
ゴキブリが来れば 例えば椅子の上に足を乗せて触らないようにとか
早くいなくなればいいなというような風に思っていたんですけれども
だんだん 壁も夜中に起きると
洗面所に例えば来ていたりとか
壁にいつもいて なんか黒いフンみたいなので壁が汚れちゃったりとか
私は賃貸なのですごい気になっていて
それでただ一方で すごく落ち込んで帰ってきた時とかは
このゴキブリは前世では私が飼っていた犬なんじゃないかって思うように
一直線に私の方にやってきて足登ってきたりとか
あと瞑想していると足の裏にずっといたりとか
なんかそういう感じでした
それで以前の法話の中で
動物と人間は分かれて暮らすっていうことを教えるために
威嚇することはたまにあるっていうことだったので
それから私はノートの切れ端を 1枚持ってきて
ゴキブリがいると下からすくい上げて
いつもその床下に逃げ込むので
その穴のところまで持っていくようなことを繰り返し
根気よく今もそれはしています
で 小さい子供のゴキブリみたいなのも結構たくさんいて
それで あのえっと たくさんいるので
たくさんいるっていうか
あの 踏んづけちゃう時とかもあって
で あの この間も踏んづけてしまって
だけど そのゴキブリ踏んづけられたまま
ちょっと半分ぐらい体が壊れたまま逃げ込んで
なのに次の日にキッチンのマットの上にそこにじっとしていて
それでもう死んじゃったのかなと思って
すいません あのえっと
あ じい様とかをイージーオブユアチャイルドっていう風にずっと経を唱えてあげると
なんかこう 足とかヒゲとかを動かして生きてるよって教えてくれるような感じなんですね
でも数時間後に行くと
もう同じことを言っても何も動かなかったりとかっていうことで
そのゴキブリには無常とか
なんで意味もないのにこんなことしてるのかなとか
すごくいろいろと教えてもらっています
だけど やっぱりその えっと
出てくると面倒くさいとか忙しいのにとか
そういうふうな気持ちが出てきて
でもそういうことの年月が続いていて
すいません こういうゴキブリとどういう風に付き合っていったらいいだろうかっていうのが質問です
すいません 長くなりました
殺虫しないでできるだけ自分の家を綺麗にしてください
ゴキブリもこの生命世界でね
ちゃんと生きてみたいなんですね
我々よりは歴史古いし
人間が消えてもゴキブリはいるし
で 氷河なんとか時代からもね
いたんだからね まあ私の家にも一匹はいるんです
それは増えませんし と
部屋を閉めてますけど
なんか無理やり一匹入っちゃって
ちっちゃい もう目に見えないぐらいちっちゃいとこ入っちゃったんですね
あ これもしかするとゴキブリの子供だなと瞬間に思ったんだけど
あまりにちっちゃいことも見えなかったんですね
今大きくなって えらいでっかい体でいるんです
私はこれは人間 もうこれは邪魔やとかいろいろやったりするんだけど
まあまあ それで自分ではその場所ちゃんと決まってあって
で 丁寧にいるんです で
外へ出る時間も決まってあって
本人がもう人間行動しない時間が夕時過ぎてからとかね
決まってますけど 残念ながら私はシャワーやったりするのは夕時半とか時とか夜ね
そういう時間だから いつでも顔を合わせることになるんです
でももうさっさとちょっと逃げて待ってるんだけどね
全然 まあ生命は生命だからね
まあそういうことで 全ての生命は生命であるっていうことを理解することと
人間が住むところは人間なりに綺麗に整理
綺麗にするのは人間の義務でしょうしね
まあそれだけのことだから
感情的になる必要はない
生命として観察すると
自分と同じく一生懸命生きている生命ということはわかるんですね
はい 以上です  はい もう一方はいかがでしょうか
ご質問 はい ですかね はい
はい じゃあはい  えーと
うちの子供のたけるからの質問ですが
お釈迦様は人間をどのように定義しているかということですか
人間  人間を他の動物と違うところ
どういうふうに定義しているって
人間は存在の中でなんか中間的な存在だからね
まあ苦しいんだけど 動物ほど苦しくはないし
あの自由はないが 動物ほどはなくてある
なんか自由がありそうで感じちゃうし
なんか動物よりは頭があるようにね
感じちゃうしね すごい中間的なんですね
だから人間という次元になったら
心成長することはできます
心の汚れを落とすことはできます
智慧を開発することはできます
中間にいるんだからね
の時点でいるんだから
マイナスしていくこともポジティブいくこともできます
そういうところです 人間というのは
例えば神々になったら
ちょっと生きることは楽なんで
ポジティブの方に行くんですね
彼らにとってはどんどんそれから下がるしかないんです
ネガティブになっちゃうと
いくらでもネガティブになれますから
それにもリミットはあるんだけどね
立ち上がるのは難しいんですね
借金している人がね あまり収入がないと
さらに借金地獄に陥るだけなんですね
金ある人にとっては もうお金使ってまた0になることは自然ですけどね
そういうことで この数字で言えば0時点でいるんですね
だからブッダの教えはポジティブにもいかないで
ネガティブにもいかないで
ここから抜けてくださいと
なぜならば 軸でどっちに行っちゃっても危険性はそのままなんです
しかし 逃げるならば ゼロのところで逃げなくちゃいけないんです
ポジティブの方にいると
そちらに引っ張られて束縛されているんですね
ネガティブにいると そちらに引っ張られて束縛されているんですね
逃げられないんです ゼロになっちゃうと逃げられます
人間っていうのはそういう次元なんです
で はい 以上です  はい では
ちょうど時間になりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
先生  では 最後の祈願の御正を唱えましょう
出てこない ドッカッパッチャチェニンドッカ
バヤンパッタチェニンバヤ
ショーカッパッタチェニッショーカ
ハントゥサンヴェーピパニノー
苦しんでない生命が苦しみなく
恐れてない生命が恐れなく
悲しんでない生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナパラマンワダンティーブッダ